i want to start with immigration today
because we're continuing to follow the
immigration situation at the u.s mexico
border
you may well know that donald trump's
presidency
saw some horrible things happen from the
standpoint of immigration including the
scaling up of the separation
of immigrant children from their parents
scaling up
of um specific types of deportations
although deportations
were actually quite high under barack
obama no progress whatsoever
on some kind of permanent status for for
daca the dreamer recipients the list
goes on and on and we've talked about
that
and as joe biden's domestic policy
during his first hundred days
has been widely successful empirically
popular
with the american people including even
with many republicans
republicans and right-wing media have
had to come up
with something that will register as a
pseudo scandal for joe biden and
criticisms of him other than simply he's
a socialist
that might resonate with the american
people and one such criticism one such
area has been immigration despite the
almost
painful double standard for us
right i mean you know the right doesn't
understand double standards or they're
not affected by them anymore but
despite what for us has been an almost
painful double standard of
them starting to pretend to care about
the kids at the border
the day that joe biden becomes president
while
they said nothing about it when donald
trump was president of the united states
they have been pushing this crisis at
the border story
and to some degree it has worked the
number of americans who believe
that the immigration situation is a
top issue has almost doubled from june i
think it was about 28 percent of
americans believed it was an emergency
situation in june now 48 percent do
they've also included in this pseudo
scandal
the numbers of increased border
crossings excuse me
during the first part of the year and as
we previously talked about that's very
deceptive because there's a big
seasonality to border crossings in the
first
quarter of the year particularly in
february and march
every year border crossings go up
this year in particular we not only saw
that for seasonal reasons
but there's also been this pent-up
demand from people who would have tried
to cross it sometime in 2020
and they did not because of the pandemic
movement was just dramatically reduced
during the pandemic so
we talked about the the kind of
seasonality of that and
why just looking at that change month to
month doesn't really tell us everything
we need to know
now there's a real new problem for
republicans pushing this and that's that
the number of unaccompanied migrant
children that are being held in these
jail-like conditions by customs and
border patrol
the number is down 84 in the span of
just a month
as of wednesday there were 954 children
remaining in these border patrol
facilities that's down from nearly 6
000 on march 28th that's an incredible
decline
per official speaking to cnn the average
time
that kids are now in border patrol
custody is down to 28 hours
it was 133 hours on march 28th
that is nearly an 80 reduction in how
long each of these kids is spending with
border patrol now
this may actually be part of why
you've been hearing less about this from
republicans for the last 10 to 14 days
it's not that they care about the facts
they've
just decided to ignore the topic because
of these numbers and
to be fair they've been distracted with
some other things as well now i'm going
to be consistent
how could i honestly say three minutes
ago
some of this fluctuation is seasonal and
now say
this is down only because of joe biden
no the
there is likely some seasonality here as
well
as to why we saw the number of children
decline
in april versus march but part of this
is because joe biden actually made it a
priority to resolve more of these cases
more quickly
and to get the numbers down now the big
picture is that this changes almost
nothing
about the urgency of finding a permanent
solution to the immigration situation
daca needs to be dealt with it's long
overdue there needs to be a permanent
solution for
uh those under the the daca program but
the point here
is that even the acute numbers that
republicans are now
cynically pointing to remember during
the trump administration they didn't
care about these children at the border
the numbers republicans are now
cynically pointing to in order to attack
joe biden
are now looking increasingly better and
better so how will right-wing media
and republicans react there's a few
possibilities part one is they may do
what they've been doing the last 10 to
14 days which is they may just stop
talking about it reminds me of the ebola
situation in 2014
leading up barack obama re-elected in
2012
then we had the campaign for the
midterms of 2014.
leading up to the midterms in november
of 2014
it was day after day after day of ebola
ebola ebola obama's handling ebola
terribly remember two people died in the
u.s i think none of those two people
even contracted it in the u.s it was
just hammering on ebola
and i said at the time not an incredibly
uh
astute uh predict didn't take much skill
uh to predict
i said this is politically motivated
after the election
there's going to be no more talk of this
and after the midterms
there was no more talk of ebola contrast
that with trump saying no one's going to
talk about covid
if i lose in november and the election's
over and of course
that was not the case because it was a
real problem actually mishandled by
trump
in any case that may be one approach
from republicans which is now that the
number of kids at the border is down 84
just don't talk about it second option
is they may just lie
and talk about it as if the numbers
don't exist or aren't available just
continue saying the same thing
they might go with unfortunately
biden has still left almost a thousand
kids at the border facilities ignoring
that that number is down 84 they may
just be more vague and say there are
still kids being held by joe biden or
something that may be one thing
you may see headlines like biden
administration
continues child detention program
that was initiated by barack obama
that'd be like a beautiful fox news
headline
that ignores what happened in the four
years intervening
but truly while knowing that this is
just
one part of the immigration problem it
is really difficult to change anything
quickly when the american federal
government is involved it's a country of
331 million people
that's why the biden vaccination program
has been so notable
that's why reducing these numbers of
kids at the border by 84
in a month there's a seasonality but it
still is an accomplishment and a
legitimate one at that
we'll see how republicans react to it
one of our sponsors
is magic spoon the breakfast cereal
that tastes just like the sugary tasty
cereals we all loved as kids but
without the sugar and without the carbs
magic spoon is sweet and delicious with
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein
and only four net carbs making it
perfect for a low carb or
keto diet and very exciting news
magic spoon has released an awesome new
flavor birthday cake
available for a limited time only but
you can still get cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon you can build your own variety
pack
our team has tried every flavor we've
looked at each flavor
really strongly and we keep asking them
to just send us more
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video